we are back here on CBS mornings at 7 30
with some new research out today showing
a big increase in the percentage of
Americans receiving mental health
treatment during the pandemic which I
actually think is good news the CDC
study shows that more than 23 percent of
adults 18 to 44 years old received
treatment last year and that is up from
18 and a half percent in 2019. the
pandemic also saw an explosion of mental
health apps and online services which
people find convenient but there can be
drawbacks our consumer investigative
correspondent Anna Werner has been
watching the industry closely and has
more of her investigation into one of
those companies Anna good morning Good
morning Tony earlier this year we told
you about cerebral it's a company that
offers affordable prescriptions and
therapy for conditions ranging from
depression to bipolar disorder since
then we've heard from more patients and
employees who are concerned about the
way cerebral diagnosis and prescribes
medications including one woman who says
cerebral mishandled her case with nearly
fatal consequences a warning the story
discusses suicide
the woman will call Yvette says she's
long suffered severe depression a result
of sexual trauma in her youth I was
constantly
depressed it was just like this
sadness a sorrow that would just take
over she says she struggled to afford
therapy but then she saw ads like these
my poor mental health was pushing
everyone in my life away until I started
using cerebral the ads from mental
health provider cerebral promised
affordable prescriptions and therapy all
online I thought I was honestly signing
up for something that was going to
change my life in a good way so she
joined first going through an assessment
like this one then the system matched
her with a prescriber and the first time
I talked to the prescriber it's only
about 10 to 15 minutes Yvette says in
that first roughly 15-minute appointment
she was prescribed three medications and
in a second appointment equally brief
she was given two more five drugs in all
but she says her symptoms got worse and
she contacted her cerebral prescriber to
tell her she was having nightmares about
hanging herself and I was scared
and when I reached out to her and I
and I was just crying to her because I
didn't know what to do
she said I don't have enough time I have
to go to my other appointment
I've already spent enough time with you
the next day a family member found her
hanging from a dog leash in her bathroom
I thought I was dreaming I thought I was
dreaming but I was I was hanging in
I didn't remember anything would you as
a psychiatrist be comfortable diagnosing
someone in 15 minutes and prescribing
medications generally no
because because it takes longer than 15
minutes to get to understand someone's
life story diagnoses have to be made in
context Dr
Whits is a clinical professor of
Psychiatry at NYU and president of the
American psychoanalytic Association
psychological diagnoses are almost by
definition far more complex and and it
requires obtaining a both a medical and
a psychological and a social history
just having that kind of conversation
takes more than 15 minutes but the
company CEO Dr David Mo maintains
cerebral's overall outcomes are positive
as he told us in June I would hope that
so I refer my close friends my family
members to use cerebral and I would say
that it's important to also see the
other side of the story which is the the
vast majority of our cases where we are
changing lives we're reducing suicidal
thinking yet a CBS news review of
cerebral's more than 1500 prescribers
listed on its website found only five
are board certified psychiatrists most
of the rest some three-quarters of
cerebral's prescribers are nurse
practitioners from Specialties outside
of mental health I find that rather
alarming diagnosing a mental illness is
a complicated Endeavor there's a reason
why it takes years of training not only
that this internal log obtained by CBS
news shows cerebral's own staffers
flagged at least 280 instances where one
patient was prescribed five plus
medications these are serious
medications that we're talking about
these things are not to be prescribed or
taken lightly after she attempted to
take her life Yvette was hospitalized
and says she underwent a lengthy
evaluation with a new Doctor Who changed
her medications did your psychiatrist
now tell you that you when you were with
cerebral that you were on the wrong
medications oh yeah she whenever she got
the list of meds that I was on she's
like I don't understand why they would
put you on this but now she says she's
feeling better you know other people
won't see your face but I can see the
relief in your face
I can see it yeah and I could and the
smile
yeah even though things happen the way
that they did I'm grateful to get the
help that I am getting now
well cerebral declined to answer our
specific questions about Yvette's case
in a statement the company said that its
clinical standards meet and exceed those
of many conventional brick and mortar
facilities and that a highly qualified
credentialing team oversees its hiring
and professional development of
patient-facing clinicians it was a
really nice interview on a very delicate
story and I I I'm struck by the data
that you were able to produce they've
got 1500 names listed on their website
but only five percent of them are
actually board certified psychiatrists
and 75 percent are nurse practitioners
with other Specialties and that's
concerning outside of mental health yeah
outside of mental health yeah right and
the company would say to you look you
know if these people have questions they
can ask those questions of the
psychiatrist you know we have a slack
Channel if there's any issues that come
up I think that Dr sulkowitz's point is
you know it's great to have access to
these online Mental Health Services
there's such a need in this country
right now but the devil's in the details
yeah that it's question of how you
handle it and I think these are some of
the questions that are coming up what
we're hearing from some of these
patients and some of these employees and
former employees is that they have
concerns about the way some of these
individual cases are playing out it's
scary to me that she tried to take her
own life apparently and didn't realize
she was doing it but she was on many
medications how do we know that cerebral
might have played a part there was many
things there that she was taking there's
a question there of what drugs she was
on and whether they were the appropriate
medications clearly her new doctor
according to her believes they were not
the correct medication the overall
mission of making mental health care
more affordable more accessible more
convenient is a good one but it does
have to be done right yeah yeah and it's
not even five percent it's five
board-certified psychiatrists thank you
very much if you or someone you know is
experiencing a mental health crisis
please do call the National Suicide
Prevention Lifeline they are always
standing by you can reach them at 988
again that is 988